[Music]
Bob the Wi-Fi isn't working up here
again can you restart the router
I already did honey I need to call the
company and have them come out hold on a
second Bob meet the Smiths they're like
your average family except well a lot
lot smaller and they've got a weird gas
pump in their house but they've still
got big Wi-Fi problems see when they
moved into this three-story house their
internet service provider installed
their modem right in the bottom corner
of their home yes that's a piece of
chocolate just go with it the basic ISP
provided router gets coverage on the
first and some of the second floor but
that third floor min I can't connect to
the third night servers yeah the signal
is very weak up there that's where the
newest crop of mesh Wi-Fi router systems
come in they help bring Wi-Fi to those
dead spots whether you live in an older
three-story house like this or a oddly
shaped City apartment or a suburban
house with a patio a backyard and a
basement a mesh can help I've been
testing six different options in a real
sized house to find the best one first
what the is a mesh network whoa Bob it's
a network created with multiple routers
that communicate with each other to give
you better wireless range and speed you
connect the main mesh Wi-Fi router in
this case a piece of gum to your home's
modem via an ethernet cord then you plug
these nodes into wall outlets around
your house in the areas you want to
spread the Wi-Fi to yes those are white
tic tacs but that's sort of what these
things look like
then after you've gone through the
really simple setup process on your
smartphone
the main mesh Wi-Fi router connects
wirelessly to those other nodes to
create a single wireless network that
covers your entire home then when you
connect your devices to that network
they get an internet connection from the
nearest node or router so that iPad and
Timmy's room will automatically connect
to the node on the third floor and if
things work right the speeds up there
will be nearly as fast as the speeds on
the first floor boom for tonight with
full singing this all sounds great but
which mesh Wi-Fi system do we buy I
tested six of the latest options in my
townhouse Plume neck ear or be Linksys
velop Google Wi-Fi gyro and Samsung
smartthings I tested three packs from
each of the companies that is one main
mesh router and two notes the erewan the
or B are my top picks both performed
really well on the floors where I had a
node
I got nearly 100 megabits per second
upload and download speeds the same as I
got on the ground floor compare that to
the router which came with my FiOS
service which can only deliver 10 to 20
megabits per second on the top floor
both smartphone companion apps have
parental controls and other types of
features
I preferred euros apps though but
Netgear has a new trick it sells a node
that doubles as an Alexa powered smart
speaker and it sounds pretty good
Alexa play our house
[Music]
one more thing Wi-Fi help you how many
nodes do we need and where do we base it
space the main router and nodes evenly
through your house favoring the areas
where you spend the most time on your
devices if you have an apartment with
some dead zones go with the 2-pack if
you have a house like the Smiths go with
a 3-pack the or B two pack costs $200
and the three pack $300 the ero two pack
costs $300 and the three pack $400 no
matter which one you choose you'll
quickly find that even just with one
node those home Wi-Fi blackouts will be
a thing of the past unless you want them
dinner's ready
dinner is ready oh look I can turn off
internet access in this app done me
[Music]